vous pensez que Pink Floyd va se
reformer un jour
feuille de depuis le 1er jour vous
publiez aujourd'hui Pink Floyd
l'histoire selon Nick Mason chez eupa
édition du chêne donc c'est un bolide
illustré qui fait 360 pages une
véritable biographie du groupe que vous
avez mis 10 ans à écrire au départ vous
étiez tous étudiants en architecture
3 300 et 4 et 3 étudiants et vous jouiez
dans des dans des salles paroissiales
qui vous était prêté oui c'est vrai que
c'est comme ça qu'on a commencé dans des
petits clubs
paroissiales et puis il y a une
émergence du seamping Floyd avec le
succès mondial de The Dark Side of The
Moon en 1973 35 millions d'exemplaires
vendus après il y a eu animaux il y a eu
the wall et alors d'abord vous tordez le
coup à une rumeur
pourtant très répandue c'est-à-dire que
Pink Floyd ça veut pas dire flamant rose
parce que les Français croient tout ça
en fait flamant rose ça se dit ping
Flamingo mais tout le monde croit que ça
veut dire flamant rose parce qu'il y a
un mec qui a dû écrire ça un jour en
fait Pink Floyd ça vient de Pink
Anderson et Floyd Queen qui sont de
bluesmen absolument inconnus non
je ne sais pas d'où ça vient j'imagine
qu'un journaliste un jour a inventé ça
un journaliste français et mais bravo à
lui parce que finalement on a commencé à
s'appeler nous-mêmes en France les
flamants roses ce qui est complètement
grotesque ouais personne est allé
regarder
alors ce qui est très étonnant dans Pink
Floyd c'est qu'il y a comme dans les
Beach Boys avec Brian Wilson qui était
le vraiment le moteur des Beach Boys il
y a eu les Rolling Stones avec Brian
Jones don Pink Floyd de début il y avait
quelqu'un qui a disparu après ces sites
barrettes c'est quelqu'un qui a vraiment
été au départ qui a donné l'élan du
groupe et qui est voilà qui est devenu
fou à cause de la drogue quoi tout
simplement
western c'est pas vraiment pourquoi il a
perdu les pédales mais en tout cas il
avait énormément d'influence et de Pink
Floyd ça n'aurait tout simplement pas
existé
35 ans après
et surtout après Dax
je crois que beaucoup ne connaissent
même pas cette barrette alors vous avez
tout essayé avec site barrette au départ
vous avez vous avez essayé de l'envoyer
voir le fameux psychiatre lynx ça n'a
rien fait vous l'avez envoyé à
fort-mahtera au Baléares passer du temps
ça n'a rien changé c'est-à-dire que
finalement il s'est éloigné de vous
petit à petit quoi
on a fait du mieux qu'on pouvait compte
tenu de ce qu'on savait à cette époque
là mais vous savez ce sont des drogues
qu'on prenaient il y a 35 ans et on ne
savait pas grand-chose on ne savait pas
très bien comment traiter les symptômes
et puis en plus
les autres trois nous étions
déterminé à devenir des stars de rock'n
roll donc c'est vrai que on aurait
peut-être pu faire preuve d'un peu plus
de compassion vous vous sentez coupable
aujourd'hui à son égard
je crois que c'est un petit peu une
culpabilité
comporte avec nous en permanence
je crois pas qu'on aurait pu faire grand
chose à vrai dire mais c'est vrai qu'on
est conscient du fait qu'on a peut-être
pas fait tout ce qu'on aurait pu faire
on s'est peut-être pas comporter comme
on aurait pu le faire c'est vrai qu'on
l'a amené à Ibiza
était toujours en vie il vit depuis 37
ans reclus il y a quand même temps vous
l'avez pas vu
depuis
ça fait 20 ans je pense
et on s'occupe encore de lui il a encore
ses royaumes
dans votre livre parce que il y a une
photo où on le voit au départ avec du
col autour des yeux avec un pushing chat
comme emporter à l'époque et puis après
il y a une photo où il y a voilà et
après il y a une photo avec tous les
membres du groupe et lui il a un peu en
retrait il y a une photo terrible c'est
quand vous enregistrez wish you Werder
en 75 il arrive sur le sur le 7 où vous
enregistrez complètement ailleurs comme
ça qu'un gros ventre et tout il passe au
milieu comme ça comme comme un fantôme
un peu
très curieux comme expérience on
s'attendait pas du tout ce qui débarque
on était en train de travailler sur un
titre ou monsieur c'est vrai que ça
parle de l'absence en fait cette chanson
là et tout à coup on ne sait même pas
d'où il est arrivé il est arrivé dans le
studio et moi je ne l'ai même pas
reconnu je dois dire
je crois que j'étais dans une autre
pièce et puis je suis arrivé
mais tu devines qui c'est
et je dis non je vois pas ils ont dit
mais c'est sides
parce que
Brian Jones lui il est mort hein donc il
est resté comme une image un peu
mythique mais il est plus là c'est un
peu comme Wilson des Beach Boys dire
qu'il lui est toujours en vie qui a
refait smile l'année dernière et c'est
des personnages comme ça qui sont des
mythes du rock n' roll foudroyés par la
drogue ça ça rejoint toutes vos
inquiétudes mon cher à guilbon mais
c'est vrai quoi c'est un personnage
extraordinaire ça c'est la première
grande rupture du groupe c'est quand
vous quand vous virez parce que vous
l'avez viré
si une barrette la deuxième grande
rupture du groupe c'est au moment de The
Wall c'est quand Roger water écrit
entièrement l'album et finit par penser
qu'il est Pink Floyd lui tout seul
et finalement il devient assez
mégalomaniaque
cette période mais nous nous n'avons pas
eu de querelle avec lui on était très
content d'avoir avec nous qui nous aide
à faire notre travail je crois que la
querelle que nous avons eu des vies et
moi-même c'était beaucoup plus tard
après 83 au moment où je voulais
absolument faire une carrière solo et il
estimait qu'une carrière solo il
n'allait pas pouvoir la faire si il
continuait d'être avec les Pink Floyd
parce que évidemment la maison de disque
dirait ça c'est inévitable c'est très
bien ton boulot solo mais quand est-ce
que tu vas recommencer à travailler avec
les Pink Floyd voilà alors le Pink Floyd
c'est terminé effectivement dans tout un
tas de de procès est-ce que je garde le
nom du groupe est-ce que c'est toi qui
le garde etc ça a été
et on a encore fait de disques après ça
alors vous vous êtes dirigé à ce
moment-là vers la course automobile si
vous êtes un grand collectionneur de
voiture et à ce moment-là vous avez vous
avez fait des courses j'ai fait les 24
Heures du Mans sur une Porsche 956 c'est
à la fin des années 70 début des années
80 que j'ai commencé à participer au 24
Heures du Mans et la Porsche 94
vous pensez que Pink Floyd va se
reformer un jour
j'espère vraiment c'est possible en tout
cas personne n'a annoncé que nous ne
retravaillerions jamais ensemble on est
encore très jeune vous savez plus ou
moins alors vous avez 60 ans depuis le
mois de janvier on va faire une
interview
61 ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors ni qu'est-ce que comme tous les
mecs de 60 ans vous avez du mal à
entendre ce que je vous dis là
[Musique]
est-ce que comme tous les mecs de 60 ans
vous avez arrêté la drogue
certainement en avoir besoin
qu'on m'aide donc je pense que je vais
recommencer est-ce que comme tous les
mecs de 60 ans vous surveillez votre
cholestérol ah oui
et c'est comme tous les mecs de 60 ans
vous comprenez rien à Internet
les ordinateurs en tout cas je m'y
connais un peu parce que depuis 15 ans
vous savez c'est pas des studios
d'enregistrement qu'on utilise des
appels Mac qu'on a dans son salon est-ce
que comme tous les mecs de 60 ans vous
comprenez rien au rap
pratiquement ceci étant dit j'ai des
enfants
s'y connaissent est-ce que comme tous
les mecs de 60 ans vous regrettez
l'époque des vinyles
vous dites que la musique aujourd'hui la
télé les fellations la vie c'était mieux
avant
peut-être que je les appréciais d'avant
par exemple
parce que comme tous les mecs de 60 ans
vous évitez de regarder en arrière parce
que ça vous déprime
il s'agit uniquement du passé et c'est
comme tous les mecs de 60 ans vous avez
peur de mourir
sans doute
peur de mourir mais en fait la course
automobile le vol c'est des choses qui
m'amusent le rock n' roll aussi c'est
des choses pour lesquelles on ne va pas
vivre très longtemps et c'est comme tous
les mecs de 60 ans il vous reste plein
de trucs à faire
oui
est-ce que comme tous les mecs de 60 ans
vous prenez du viagra sans le dire
non pas encore et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de innarditude abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu